the flight from damascus landed in
baghdad
under the cover of darkness
iran's most powerful spymaster stepped
off the plane
to be met by a trusted ally major
general qasim silimani
and the senior iraqi militia commander
then climbed
into one of two waiting vehicles they
headed towards the main road
leading from the airport to the city
centre
but the two men and their entourage
would never make it that far
suddenly rockets fired from an american
drone
flying in the night sky exploded through
the two vehicles
killing everyone inside
last night of my direction the united
states military successfully
executed a flawless precision strike
that killed the number one
terrorist anywhere in the world then u.s
president donald trump
claimed qasim suleimani had been
plotting
imminent and sinister attacks on
american diplomats and military
personnel
but we caught him in the act
and terminated him then perhaps more in
hope
he added we took action last night to
stop
a war we did not
take action to start a war
there was nothing gray or ambiguous
about the us airstrike
but the high-profile killing of such an
important figure
sent a clear message to iran to stop
harming u.s interests
in a gray zone of confrontation between
the two countries
the attack also sought to weaken what's
seen as tehran's most
potent gray zone weapon a network of
proxy forces
operating in iraq lebanon syria
yemen and beyond what distinguishes what
iran and perhaps some others are doing
is the way that these forces are
actually active
on battlefields or in countries carrying
out kinetic activity
as well as just sheer intimidation
assassination qasim suleimani was at the
heart of this operation
a hidden hand behind deniable attacks
across the middle east
evidence that the gray zone can be a
great equalizer
for those wanting to challenge a
superpower
my name is deborah haynes i'm the
foreign affairs editor at sky news
and you're listening to my podcast into
the gray zone
which explores a murky evolution of
warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill in this
episode
we look at how states attack each other
indirectly
via proxy forces and track a gray zone
conflict
between iran and the united states that
nearly ignited a real war
[Music]
[Music]
i think it's it's accurate to describe
iran
a little bit as feeling our edges if you
will
on actual battlefields or would-be
battlefields and certainly in cyberspace
general david petraeus is a former
director of the central intelligence
agency
the cia though he's better known for his
long military career
i've interviewed him several times since
2007
first in iraq then at central command in
tampa florida
and finally when he was in charge of
us-led
troops in afghanistan his career
meant he saw firsthand how iran
allegedly
operates in the gray zone the clever and
often deniable use of partner forces
is one of the regime's core strengths
it's a strategy
tehran honed when training equipping and
financing
the lebanese group hezbollah in the
1980s helping
in its campaign of resistance against
israel's occupation of southern lebanon
if you think what iran does with its
proxies
lebanese hezbollah the various militias
the shia militias that it supports in
iraq
uh in syria uh to a degree in yemen and
some other places
um that is really quite skillful and
indeed
has an effect in these countries
would you say that iran is actually out
of all the countries that are playing in
this space
iran is the most effective at using
proxies in the gray zone to achieve
foreign policy goals well there
certainly are other countries that are
making effective use of them as well if
you look what russia does with the
wagner group
he's referring to a russian private
military company
mercenaries from the wagner group are
deployed in trouble spots and conflict
zones like
syria and libya reportedly in support of
russian forces
though moscow denies any state
involvement in their activities
the truth is we've all sought to have
again allies and partners and so forth
but
what distinguishes what iran and russia
and perhaps some others are doing
uh is the way that these forces are
actually active
on battlefields or in countries uh
carrying out kinetic activity
as well as just sheer intimidation
assassination uh pressure
uh crime uh and all the rest of this
and that can be uh effective
in certain ways in certain countries
and iran has shown a facility for that
certainly
using proxy forces to fight an enemy
indirectly
often in a third country is something
many nations
big and small have done for centuries
just think back to the cold war
and the various conflicts that flared up
around the world
with the united states and the then
soviet union
backing opposing sides but for iran
this grey's own tool of proxy militias
is not simply a clever tactic
to attack an enemy it's perhaps the only
way
tehran can hope to level the playing
field when competing against
regional powers like saudi arabia and
israel
and a superpower like the united states
the kudz force conducts overseas
operations
as part of the elite islamic
revolutionary guard corps
or irgc including allegedly running
iran's proxies
for more than 20 years that kutz force
was headed by major general qasim
suleimani
his name became infamous among the u.s
led coalition in iraq
after the 2003 invasion to topple saddam
hussein
iranian-backed militias were accused of
targeting
american and british troops he wasn't
just
the equivalent if you will of the u.s
central command commander the equivalent
of the
joint special operations command
commander the counterterrorism the
equivalent of the cia director
for covert action and so forth he was
also the equivalent of a regional
envoy all in one person which is what
made him
such a very formidable uh adversary
and can you describe the kind of
communications that you had with him
well we had very limited communications
uh
i would periodically send a message
through
there were a handful of people that we
knew had direct contact with him
i asked the general whether he ever met
with suleimani
oh i never would have met with him he
wanted to meet with me i'm not pretty
sure
because it would have elevated his
status very considerably one of
suleimani's goals in iraq
had been to prevent the united states
from establishing a permanent presence
on iran's doorstep following the 2003
invasion
he and the revolutionary guard allegedly
did this
via proxy militias we had all
seen iran operating really effectively
against our own interests in a number of
things in the middle east and the
question that
we asked ourselves and i think is
relevant here is
um if you're going to do grazing warfare
you know how do you do it so how do the
successful
practitioners do it john rain is a
former diplomat
who now works for the international
institute for strategic studies
a think tank in london he co-authored a
report on iran's network
of partner and proxy forces which was
assembled
in the wake of the iranian revolution in
1979
the particular aspect that we looked at
in iran
and the one that i think defines
their capability is
is the ability to operate through third
parties partners proxies
call them what you like but it's using
other people
in other theaters to achieve your
objectives
and that kind of lay at the heart of
iran's capability and it wasn't entirely
by accident
they came to this because they they
didn't have the ability to reach
parity and conventional weapons with
their regional adversaries let alone
with the us
or israel he said this capability
capitalized on the spirit of the
revolution which saw the overthrow of
iran's u.s backed shah
and the creation of an islamic republic
under a hard-line cleric
the irgc was formed to defend this new
political system
its commanders including suleimani when
he was alive
report directly to iran's supreme leader
the second thing they had was all sorts
of networks
of connections
and patronage this includes extremist
elements within sheer communities across
the middle east
there were thirdly amongst these
communities
very strong feelings of being
marginalized not having a voice
always being the junior partner so iran
had those three advantages
which it played to but the critical
thing that it did
they made it a capability he claimed
this involved iran helping to train
partners and proxies in different
countries to a point where they could be
mobilized
to fight in support of iranian interests
this includes forces loyal to syria's
president
bashar al-assad the houthi militants in
yemen
and of course iraq's powerful militias
i think they saw an enormous opportunity
to
put themselves forward as essentially
the
alternative to to an iraq
that was dominated by the west that had
in many ways lost its political and
cultural independence and
they systematically exploited that both
through their contacts with militias
and through a broader maneuvering just
to get inside the security machinery
of the state and if you look now um and
certainly in the last four or five
years what the iranians have managed to
do
it does look very much like a form of
state capture
the united states watched iran's growing
network of influence with concern
in fact it was one of the reasons donald
trump gave
when he started to attack a historic
nuclear deal
between the iranian regime and six
global powers
signed in 2015. one of his biggest
foreign policy act as president
was to pull the us out of the deal
setting in train a series of gray zone
clashes with tehran
that threatened to plunge the middle
east into all-out war
from sourdough supremos
cheese on toast champions
we've all caught kitchen fever oven
cleaning duties
not so trendy luckily the hot point
single oven has all that covered
the assisted cleaning function lets you
clean your oven while saving on energy
and skipping harmful products we'll even
give you one in 10 chance to win your
oven for free
plus free next day delivery and
recycling but curry's pc world
teas and seas apply until the spark
there isn't a spark anne-marie trevelyan
was a british defense minister
as tensions flared between the us and
iran
it's not that everyone's waiting on
tender hooks for the for the for the
spark to go
boom it's that you live in that
continuum of instability
and everybody has their way of
delivering
and you know understanding the
environment waiting
uh hoping that of course there is never
a stock
the iran deal is defective at its core
president trump though brought a new
element of combustibility to the middle
east
in may 2018 with these words i am
announcing today
that the united states will withdraw
from the iran nuclear deal
the u.s began reinstating economic
sanctions against iran
under a policy called maximum pressure
aimed at forcing iran back to the
negotiating table
we will be instituting the highest level
of economic sanction sanctions had been
lifted
as part of the nuclear deal with
international powers
including the uk france and germany in
return
iran had agreed to limit its uranium
enrichment
and other activities that were suspected
of being part
of a hidden nuclear weapons program the
europeans opposed the u.s move
but could do little to stop tensions
escalating
the following may 2019 in waters off the
united arab emirates
explosions were reported on four large
oil tankers
the u.s accused iran of attempting to
disrupt the flow of oil and gas
through the strait of hormuz a vital
waterway
off the iranian coast where much of the
world's energy passes
tehran denied the charges so that was a
that was a
very interesting and you know quite
complex challenge because as you say the
straits of humus are
a critical you know choke point as it's
known
how was that a gray zone incident i
think for me
it's you know you've got a you've got a
stretch of water and you've got
big ships full of oil and other
flammable
materials that's how i think of it you
know you know they're enormous these
things if you go and sort of stand by
them they're vast yeah they are really
huge
they are huge i spent quite a bit of
time out there in the summer actually
going and
looking at the sea yeah yeah and it's
quite a narrow bit of sea
with big ships in it and you know the
waterway is narrow and there's this sort
of kink and the ships have to go around
it and they come very close to
the iranian you know seas and border
and you know one of the ways that
you know the iranians like to you know
remind everybody that they're there
and that they could you know cause
mischief if they want to
is with the sort of these these fast
boats that they
kind of whizz up to these uh big ships
and
it's sort of like a swarm of mosquitoes
coming at you
and mostly just do that and you know
wave guns and then go
back to the shore again and so they want
no one's terribly surprised by seeing
them around
you know it's that prodding uh just to
make the point so that's the great end
but
it can flip very quickly from
we know you're here and you're you could
disrupt to oh
you actually are disrupt a month later
two more tankers were mysteriously
attacked
then on the 20th of june iran
shot down a large u.s drone claiming it
had entered its airspace
the u.s hit back with cyber attacks but
aborted plans to launch more
conventional airstrikes
still this gray zone crisis was far from
over
it even touched the british overseas
territory of gibraltar
thousands of miles away i remember very
vividly when we were
informed of what was happening there was
a tanker coming in our direction
it was loaded with oil that was subject
to
sanctions fabian picado is gibraltar's
chief minister
he's talking about the moments leading
up to the 4th of july 2019
when gibraltar police and british royal
marines
seized an iranian super tanker off his
coast
the grace one was accused of carrying
oil bound for syria
in breach of eu sanctions was it kind of
a nerve-wracking anxious time when when
you made that decision
i don't think you make good decisions if
you allow yourself to become nervous
about making them
the only way to make good decisions is
to be dispassionate about them and to be
objective about the decision that you're
going to make
and not be nervous about what the
consequences are if you fault things
through sufficiently
and if you've you know done an analysis
careful analysis
of what you're going to do why you're
going to do it and how you're going to
do it
that is the best antidote to to
nervousness
his nerves were tested again in a
meeting with a senior iranian diplomat
i must tell you it wasn't pleasant to
sit across from the
uh deputy ambassador in london and be
told as we were trying to resolve this
straight in the eye mr piccardo 70
million iranians know who you are
to which my response was well your 32
thousand gibraltarians are looking
carefully at everything that i do
and i must ensure that i act in keeping
with gibraltar law
at all times what was that why was he
saying what was he implying do you think
by that threat
well i don't think that he was implying
that i was very popular in tehran put it
that way
barely two weeks after the seizure
iranian forces
captured a british flag tanker the stena
impero
as it travelled in omani waters off the
coast of iran
a tip tanker spat with gibraltar stuck
in the middle and what did it feel like
though when the steno imperial
was uh was impounded so obviously
concerning
concerning because the sydney imperial
was crewed by
individuals who should not be put at
risk
did it seem quite surreal though like he
this was kind of
it was it was like a it was a conflict
really between
the us and iran um but being played out
obviously under the threshold of war um
but with
real lives real cons real world
consequences
and kind of tankers being used as pawns
the fact that the action being played
out in our waters or in our
closer strategic area of operation
might somehow have a global consequence
is nothing new
in our history we have always had that
reality make us more relevant perhaps
than our size
might suggest and what do you say
to those who at the time were
critical of gibraltar um and the uk
really saying that they were moving to
seize this
tanker um under pressure from the united
states
to uh to ramp up that policy of the u.s
of maximum
pressure on iran that actually rather
than
um you know applying the law
uh the european laws sanction laws as
you would normally have done
um actually you you were you're just
merely a tool
of u.s foreign policy or uk foreign
policy
there are some fantasists out there who
believe that for the purposes of their
political analysis
you know they can say things that might
wash the law is the law
we're not entitled to stop anyone
traversing our waters or walking down
our streets simply because
we might or might not like them at a
foreign policy level
there was no power to detain if the
provisions of
european sanctions and gibraltar law
applying them did not provide
for that there was no power to release
unless there was compliance with that
so you know we could we could write a
magnificent novel
on the basis of what you put to me but
we couldn't detain the vessel and we
couldn't
release a vessel on that basis the grace
one and the cena imperial
were eventually released but the threat
to international shipping in the gulf
prompted countries like the uk the us
and france
to send extra warships to help patrol
the waterway
and deter more attacks like everything
in the gray zone though hostilities can
come in a variety of different
forms and can happen anywhere at any
time
that's the challenge and that's the
challenge of modern
uh you know warfare and you know
international relationships it's that
nobody really wants the sparks because
we are
we all have you know big bad weapons i'm
speaking to anne-marie trevelyan
in her office in the houses of
parliament in october 2020.
we all have seen the impacts of the
ultimate deterrence
at work at the end of the second world
war and actually that has
that has created having nuclear
deterrence has created this era of peace
in big aggressive military terms
what it has done is pushed push the need
for countries to
you know exert their authority make
their point
try and you know make themselves more
important in the hierarchy of
um you know nations in the world
by doing things in a less
obvious you know less direct way um
you know subdiffusion underhand behavior
disruptive behavior um controlling
behavior
and i think we have to we can't we can't
pretend it's not there
and we have to be alive to it but also i
think
we if that is going to be where
more disruption can be achieved we have
to be willing to say that's also not
acceptable
the u.s appeared to reach that point in
december 2019
when an iraqi militia linked to tehran
was blamed for killing
an american iraqi contractor in a rocket
attack in northern iraq
the qatari hezbollah militia is part of
iraq's
powerful semi-official popular
mobilization forces
they played a key role in helping the
iraqi military
reclaim territory from the extremist
group islamic state
after it took control of large parts of
the country in 2014
as we heard about in the previous
episode
but there had been growing unhappiness
at iranian influence in iraq
which stretched from the militias into
political parties and the government
this erupted into months of
anti-government protests in majority
shia areas of southern and central iraq
that are usually more pro-iran on a
number of occasions
iranian consulates were even burned down
as a symbol of uh protests against
iranian influence and iranian backing of
corrupt political leaders um
even the slogan the main slogan of the
protest was
we want the nation nuridwatan we demand
the nation meaning
that we do not accept others to
interfere
especially iran's influence over iraq
this iraqi mp spoke to me about the
unfolding chaos
but asked not to be named for security
reasons
referring to how iran viewed the
protests she said
yes they were disturbed by this
obviously
they were more disturbed than they would
have been at the protesters being
kurds or sunnis because it is these
people they claim to
represent the poor
and middle class shia iraq and and do
you think the attacks on the
american base um
[Music]
um biker type has bola do you think that
was kind of like a distraction tactic
to try to um divert attention away from
the protests
or where did you think that come from
that came from
so it is showing um flexing muscles
showing that they have
control over iraq they can do what they
like uh
and and no one can stop them from doing
so
because they are in control this is my
feeling about
it but the rocket strike that killed the
american iraqi contractor
on the 27th of december prompted the us
to launch airstrikes against the qatar
hezbollah group
that triggered angry protests by
militiamen outside the american embassy
in baghdad
i felt that my country was kidnapped by
by a few people who own who have arms
and to have money
and who have the support and the
majority of iraqis including myself
are left without uh any support
from our allies this is how i felt
because it was it did it did kind of
make iraq
this like proxy battlefield between the
us and iran
absolutely this is obvious that iraq is
the battleground in a battle that it has
no part of
iraq is not at war with the us iraq is
not at war with iran
yet iraq is where it all happens
this is why i thought it was kidnapped
my country was
being kidnapped three days after the
embassy protest
qasim suleimani touched down at baghdad
airport
he was met by the founder of the qatari
hezbollah group
abu mehdi al-mahandis when the u.s drone
then opened fire
the two men died together iran's
spymaster
and one of iran's alleged proxy militia
leaders
the world braced for what would happen
next
just on on kasim suleimani what did you
think how did you feel when you heard
the news that he had been killed
it was outrageous that the united states
murdered the person and his iraqi and
iranian friends
who were key to defeating isis professor
syed morandi
is an iranian-american academic who
works at tehran university
the united states which through its
regional allies like saudi arabia
and turkey and others were the reason
why
this region isn't a mess and the reason
why which these
extremist groups came to power
they went and murdered the person who on
the ground
led the troops that fought against isis
and defeated isis so i was outraged
that this hero was murdered i challenged
the professor on this
saying the us had justified its action
because it accused suleimani of having
the blood of american and british
soldiers on his hands
right that's the same united states that
lied itself into iraq
that lied about weapons of mass
destruction in iraq
the same united states that lied about a
relationship between
al qaeda and saddam hussein that's the
same united states that lied about qasim
suleimani
and when the americans have a history of
lying i don't see any reason
why i should trust anything that the
americans say
hundreds of thousands of people took to
the streets across iran
to mourn suleimani's death while the
supreme leader
ayatollah khamenei vowed a harsh
retaliation
so it was a very long weekend that one
it wasn't much sleeping that went on
over there no i don't think i don't
think the secretary of state of defense
or i had much sleep
at all nor did any of our any of our
teams and can you remember how you felt
when that spark
did go off it was very shocking
it was a very shocking thing to happen
um i think that my first thought process
was
not unreasonable because this man has
been directing
you know elite forces to do some pretty
nasty things in a lot of places
if this was on a battlefield in an old
you know in a
you know henry v kind of way that would
be okay you'd take out
the enemy general don't you and that's
what sulaimani was
but of course he was much more than that
to the iranian
community and the political leadership
so the impact wasn't just that general's
trying to make his troops
kill my troops if i take him out i win
it's
it's not that simple anymore so the
impact was much greater on
on the whole of the iranian perspective
but it was the the
that question of what happens next
good morning
that started to become clear five days
later when iran launched a series of
ballistic missiles
against u.s troops in military bases in
iraq
despite the barrage no soldiers were
killed
though iran's air defenses on high alert
for a u.s counter-attack
then accidentally shot down a ukrainian
passenger jet
taking off from tehran all 176 people
on board perished analysts warned of
regional war
but president trump chose not to
escalate
our great american forces are prepared
for anything
iran appears to be standing down
which is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing
for the world iran didn't go further
either
not openly though it's thought to have
been attempting to avenge soleimani's
death
in a more covert deniable grey's own way
whether justified or not the
assassination would have sent a message
to tehran that there was a limit
to the hostilities washington was
willing to absorb
i do think that that strike was
very important in restoring a sense of
deterrence
between the us and iran directly
general petraeus uh if you think about
deterrence of course is not just
capability
adversary's perception of your
capability it's also the adversary's
perception of your will
and i think it's it's fair to question
whether the iranians thought we were
going to respond
after certain provocations such as the
downing of a 130 million
drone over the strait of vermouth the
hijacking of multiple
uh oil tankers in the gulf the strike
against the upcake oil facility
in saudi arabia that took five percent
of the world's oil production offline
he's referring to drone attacks against
two major oil installations
inside saudi arabia in september 2019
that were claimed by iranian-backed
houthi rebels in yemen
and we didn't really do anything after
any of those
and then it was when an american was
killed a contractor in fact
in iraq and some soldiers were wounded
uh that seemed to be the last straw for
president trump
and he decided at that time apparently
reportedly
uh to authorize the operation against
casa solomoni
just as how genuine military power and
the willingness to use it
can deter states from launching a
conventional attack
so too can it reduce hostilities from
proxies in the gray zone
another option is to fight back covertly
as well
we used to sit around in central command
and at the cia at times and think
you know what is it that we could do to
them that they would know that we did it
it wouldn't be very visible they
wouldn't feel that they would have to
respond
they wouldn't be certain we did it but
they'd think we did it
and you know we'd know that they know
this kind of activity back and forth
and that can remind them as well that
there are consequences and there have
undoubtedly been some of those
kinds of activities as well without
going into specifics and
uh what it is that could be done but you
can i mean i think an imagination
can come up with these pretty easily
sadly
he didn't offer any further clues but
it's not hard to find reports of
mysterious explosions or cyber attacks
in iran
that no one's claimed responsibility for
like the assassination
in november 2020 of a top iranian
scientist
suspected of masterminding tehran's
covert efforts to build a nuclear weapon
iranian officials have accused israel of
being behind the shooting
of mohsin fakhrizadeh just outside
tehran
and threatened retaliation as we heard
in episode 1
assassinations are at the sharp end of
the various tools
used by states against each other in the
gray zone
israel has declined to comment all the
people that were attacked by the iranian
proxies
have learned how to cope with it with
collecting intelligence
exposing diplomatically what the
iranians are doing and
from time to time even using the same
methods
that's major general amos yadlin a
former military intelligence chief
from the israel defense force i spoke to
him before the assassination of the
nuclear scientist
you are conducting a counter operation
without taking all the time
responsibility and in a way
playing with the same rules of the game
that the iranians are playing
why is that necessary why do you have to
also push back in the gray zone
iran is far away iran is a is a
very large country and
in a way israel is not looking for a war
with iran
israel wants to avoid the war with iran
as i told you before
it is well known in the 21st century
you gain almost nothing from war but
you want to uh
to cope with the sweats we've seen um
custom silimani being
assassinated at the beginning of this
year in your opinion
what was the what has been the effect of
that
i think uh the fact that he was removed
uh he's making the the middle east a
better place
not a heaven but less hellish
and i think that iran haven't found
a replacement yet even though history
told us that
to every to every
personalities that passed away
sooner or later somebody feel filled the
vacuum
but for the time being
i think also the iranian reaction
was much less than
people predicted or were afraid of
some very serious analysts in the
u.s thought that this is going to be a
war
i think this is a very good
example that if you choose
smartly your targets and attack them
surgically not every
operation is a slippery slope for a
full-scale war
iran views the world very differently
and what do you say to to those who
accuse iran of
of not playing by the rules of of using
dirty tricks like cyber attacks
and these these these proxy militias
um to to carry out attacks against
um enemies like the united states and
and and the uk
um because that's the only way iran can
fight because
obviously iran's military is much it's
not as strong as the us armed forces for
example
professor morandi again so iran supports
a popular organizations that expel
the israelis from their from lebanon
that expels
isis from iraq and popular groups in
yemen
that resist the saudi invasion of the
country
and these are militias and they are
somehow illegitimate
yet the invasion and destruction of iraq
the destruction
of afghanistan the invasion of
afghanistan and the support for the
saudis on
in the siege of yemen that is somehow
legitimate
the maximum pressure campaign in iran to
starve ordinary iranians of medicine and
food
that is somehow legitimate i think
the issue of morality here and
the rule of law is the other way around
it is western countries that see
themselves
as above the law and therefore their
regional proxies
behave lawlessly along with them as well
clearly little about this crisis is
black and white
it makes rather aptly for the purposes
of this podcast
for a rather gray zone where the risk
remains of miscalculation by either side
that pushes iran into direct conflict
with the united
states but what about
when there are gray zone hostilities
between the world's superpower
and its biggest rival i'm afraid that
the world is is going
i hope not towards decoupling but but i
think
diverging in is inevitable um
partly because our political systems are
very different
uh and any thought of political reform
in china
i think is is well off the menu for the
immediate future our economic systems
are increasingly difficult as china
pushes very much a state model and our
value systems are
increasingly different but that's next
time as we continue
into the gray zone
[Music]
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott
with production support from sophia
mcbride and michael greenfield
and narrated by me debra haynes
the head of sky news radio is dave
terrace
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts
you